hello everyone january is here and that
means we are back with the 81st edition
of the tata steel chess tournament it's
again between england and magnus carlsen
I already mentioned on Twitter that I'm
psyched about seeing ding we were in
playing classical chess again his games
are always a really powerful and really
you know packed with imagination and
really awesome lines and who better to
test such aggressive play than Magnus
Carlsen playing with the black pieces
now Carson is the defending champion he
won't attack us till 2018 if you
remember he tied with onigiri and then
he went they went it the tiebreaks
Magnus Carlsen was able to win it so he
is the defending champion and I believe
this will be Carlson's first classical
game after the 2018 World Chess
Championship match against Fabiano
Caruana ah he did play the world rapid
and bliss but those are rapid in blades
so it's gonna be an awesome game I do
hope you enjoy it the time format is the
same as always
I believe they don't change this it's
100 minutes for the first 40 moves then
you get 15 minutes more and of course
it's 30 seconds increment for every move
and if there is a tie at the end of the
tournament like in the previous were
unleashing the Magnus tied there will be
a playoff for the it will be I believe
about five plus three bliss games and
then if that's a tie then we go into
Armageddon but yeah let's get back to
this game it's really a wild one Dingley
run opens with Knight to f3 so we have
the reti on the board Knight of 6 g 3
and B 5 this is the spiciest variation
of the Kings Indian attack of the reti
really and an interesting choice taking
hold of the C 4 square preparing c5 to
really take hold of the center and also
at some point black might also decides
to develop the light square bishop but
white of course it will be faster we
have B 4 e 6 and now Bishop to g5 and c5
by Carlsen
now if Bishop 2 G 2 here then there is
one game in the database that already
reached this position was gata Kamsky
versus wesley so in 2015 where where was
the soul won a very nice game with the
black pieces but here
improves with d5 and it's already moved
five and we have a new position on the
board that has never been reached before
so what do you do here if you play
captures here then it's a it's a
playable move but let's say after Bishop
captures Queen captures and f6 white
might get the idea playing Queen
captures on d5 saying okay out if you
grab on b2 I'll capture your rook and
I'm faster you know with capturing
groups but it doesn't work if Queen
captures Queen captures then black will
not capture the rook but instead Queen
c1 checkmate so there are some tricks
here so after defog would have Queen to
a5 with Czech unpinning here so now the
knight can move knight is able to
capture on d5 if this is blocked by
let's say c3 or Knight B - so we have
Bishop the back to d2 forcing Carlson's
Queen back Queen to b6 and now D
captures any 6 f captures any sex yes
you do somewhat ruin your king side but
you are now creating a very powerful
Center after d5 comes it will be a
really insane control of the central
squares a for inviting and now B 4 and a
5 pushing the Queen back Queen to d8
cross and retreats with the Queen right
at the starting square and now butter up
the G - I'm that rockin a 8 and here
Carlsen could go something like a bishop
to b7 but you can't but then you
constantly have to keep an eye on okay
if I develop my Knights then a 6 is
coming and then 95 okay I'm definitely
losing the rook
so here Carlson takes a different
approach we have nice the c6 offering
the possibility of going nice to e5 and
he takes it we have 95 and now you can't
really go Bishop to b7 we already
mentioned it a six is a constant problem
for black you will have to go back and
then you're just losing the exchange and
the pawn here after but should be seven
captures captures white can just castle
all is well here so after 95 we have
Knight captures on e5 magnus carlsen
here decides to sacrifice the exchange
Bishop captures on a 8 and now d5
closing this closing up this position on
May 8th so until this bishop returns
into the game black we we could say it's
really up material and there are a
couple of very interesting lines for
example if the
it's the castle here and black decides
to play some better place six with ideas
of winning this Bishop it's not all that
simple because Bishop to f4 you attack
the knight on e5 that's undefended and
also the piece that protects the c6
square so if the knight moves or if the
knight is captured then the shop to c6
check and Bishop escapes via sorry not
that but a VI a four and here we already
mentioned what happens if that but if
Knight f d7 defending this nice then you
get Bishop captures on d5 I'm sure if in
this position think it would would have
gone for something like this grabbing
two extra points for a bishop and the
would call since King still in the
center it would give a white a very
powerful attack now let's say Queen f6
rook to d1 and so on and so on but ding
decides to go a six he already creates
an outpost for his Bishop on b7 so
there's really no no trouble of the
bishop being captured and now you can no
longer go better basics because white
will simply capture the bishop so Bishop
to d7 by Carson we have rush of the b7
nada but should be safe here and Bishop
to d6 calls and prepares to castle
we have Bishop back to g5 pinning the
knight nice to f7 attacking the bishop
and now Bishop captures on f6 Queen
captures on f6 attacking the b2 pawn
but now Knight the b2 and you could
capture unbe to immediately but then e 4
is coming the your king is still in the
center so perhaps you want to get your
King to safety before trying anything
else after 92 we have castles by Carson
and now we have also castles by Dean you
could protect the pawn via via rook to
be won but that's just not the kind of a
player that ding is Queen captures on b2
and now comes he for ding decides to
give it up to for some activity as he's
already up material and now of course if
you capture in night c4 attacks the
Queen and the bishop here the bishop is
attacked twice we had the Queen and the
night and after after something like 24
it doesn't really help you you can just
go Knight captures and after Knight
captures Queen e1 and there's no good
defense against Ruby d1 as you can't
protect both the night and the
here so after E for Queen D for cross
and retreats with the Queen and now ich
after Sun d5 and instead of capturing
and allowing this Bishop to enter the
game we have E 5 and okay Knight B 3
attacks the Queen Queen 24 and now Queen
D 3 ding wants to trade Queens but
cousin isn't interests the Queen before
preparing a nice King side attack via
Knight g5 and then Knight to f3 and here
ding has to be very careful if he has to
play f3 if you play something let's say
rock a5 if he disregards the dangerous
on the King side goes after the c5 pawn
let's say then you get Knights the g5
like we said and then it's too late to
protect the f3 square you can go Knight
d2 to guard it this way but it doesn't
help unite it should recheck and now
either you'll go Kim G 2 and Knight f4
check wins the Queen has the G pawn is
pinned or you could go to h1 but still
doesn't really help you Knight captures
enough to check completely bust open the
Kings side and black is now just winning
so after Queen g4 dingos f3 attacks the
Queen Queen to h5 and now Knight d2
giving further protection to the f3 pawn
and perhaps if the pawn will ever be not
under attack then the knight can jump
straight back into the game Knight g5
pressuring the f3 pawn also with ideas
of perhaps coming to h3 but the bishop
also is eyeing the h3 square Bishop to
c6 trying to exchange bishops but also
to create a powerful passed pawn and c6
and now call someplace special to h3 and
here you don't really have a good way of
saving the rook that's the problem for
white here if you try a rope to f2 then
you get Bishop to f5 you move the bishop
we are an attack on the Queen and 3d h3
Square and there is no defense against
this once the Queen is moved knight
recheck picks up the rook and then black
will just be much better on the other
hand after Bishop to h3 you could try
something like rook fe1 but then there's
a different plant c4 you either try to
get a white two at the capture on c4 but
the Queen and Knight are both needed
regarding the f3 pawn and also you are
freeing up this diagonal Bishop to c5
check will be very powerful
and then after Queen III blocking Bishop
to c5 you get c3 kicking away the night
from the defense of the f3 pawn 94 and
now simply Knight capture sum of three
will elite the checkmate in in any line
King h1 Bishop g2 check now you can
sacrifice it can capture screen captures
King f1 and now well
Knight d2 will be a nice discovered
check from the rook but also it's a
double check which means it's checkmate
so there's no good way to save the rook
so dingos Bishop to b5 he gives back the
extra exchange the exchange Bishop
captures the rook we have rook captures
on f1 and now comes Rock captures on f3
Knight captures on f3 and now II for
attacking both the knight and the Queen
Queen to e3 and now Knight captures an
f3 and here simply rook captures on f3
because the rook cannot be captured by
the pawn
that's something going endings favor if
you capture it then I'm sure you all see
how white wins but if not feel free to
pause the video and try to see how white
wins this position I'll give you a
couple of seconds as usual for those of
you who found it - congratulations it's
a very nice tactic and the photos if you
just want to enjoy the show
quinta east sex is the idea now whatever
you decide to play here if you go King
to h8 then Queen to see it will lead to
the checkmate after black gives away all
of the pieces Queen f8 will lead the
checkmate and on the other hand if you
go something like King to f8 then it's a
bit of a different idea but still Queen
captures and e6 you just lose a piece
and then being down a piece you will
quickly fall at the checkmate here you
have to give up your queen and it's over
soon rush be a checkmate and lastly but
not leastly of course after Queen 3 6
check Queen f7 can block but still you
just lose a piece and then there's
there's no good counter play f2 check
doesn't really do anything F 1 square is
guarded by the bishop but you can also
block with your king and then there are
no more dangerous and no more tricks
so after this rook captures on f3 cross
and played Queen captures on f3 we have
Queen captures pawn captures and king -
f2 after king 2f to the players agreed
to a draw as the
is nothing more to be done here after
scolson starts bringing his King into
the game dingle capture on f3 and now we
have a know an end game which opposite
colored bishops both sides have five
points so there's really no way either
side can ever win this swim definitely
and I start and always an explosive game
between cross and and being really
really happy about that and I hope I
think we'll be able to finish the
tournament this time as well he did fall
off a bicycle and broke his hip on his
previous classical tournament that he
played so hopefully that never happens
again as he's always always a joy to
have him and any tournament yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank he'll call and and
North's gonna grab guy Michael Cabral
Mario and samosa and then you'll
Rosenblatt for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos your thing called for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the capablanca saga but also
checking up on some of the other games
from the Tata Steel 2019 we didn't talk
about the other results as I will most
likely show another game from this
tournament sometime tomorrow morning the
most likely and then we're gonna check
up on the results and the other players
thank you all and I will see you soon